welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and with d23
going in today to marvel have begun
announcing more of their upcoming movies
in the face wall panel Marvel President
Kevin Feige announced she-hulk
Moon Knight and MS marvel as coming to
streaming service Disney Plus yesterday
and today has had some pretty big
announcements - whilst this new list
isn't huge there's still some things of
note to take from it including the Kit
Harington casting which was announced
during the panel I'll get into that
later but I'll just break down things as
they happened the first announcement
came with the confirmation of Black
Panther - which will be dropping on May
6 2022 the film is set to reprise the
majority of its cast and it's rumored
that Michael B Jordan - will be making a
return as Kel monger who will
communicate with the titular character
on the spiritual plane we did know that
this movie was in the making so it's not
a huge announcement though it's nice to
have the date set in stone for the film
and confirmation at phase four will
definitely have at least one huge huge
film as some have said that the lineup
is slightly understated the following
announcement centered around the
Eternals cast and we opened with the
news that Jemma Chan would be playing
the role of Cersei and the upcoming film
many thought that this role would be
going to Angelina Jolie and the channe
would reprise her role from Captain
Marvel though this will not be the case
Kit Harington was also announced as Dane
Whitman aka Black Knight though Black
Knight predominantly features in the
Eternals the character has also been a
part of the Avengers at several points
and Kevin Feige in the past has
suggested that going forward the team
will look a lot different which Knight
could add this diversity to and though
we don't have the specifics just yet
from here we got a full lineup of the
entire cast who all came out on stage
and waved to the crowd
this was made up of Richard Madden
Kumail Nanjiani lauren riddle off a
Brian Tyree Henry is Salma Hayek William
Q Don Lee Angelina Jolie Jemma Chan and
of course Kit Harington finally we got
the same footage of Black Widow that was
shown at San Diego comic-con last month
the cast of the film did appear in a
video
say that they are still filming but that
the footage will more than make up for
their absence I've already done a full
breakdown of this video if you want to
check it out on the channel and there's
quite a lot to cover so definitely watch
that after this it features taskmaster
and I go into my theories so it's
definitely worth checking if you want to
know more
we did get rumors that there would be
some phase 5 news but this doesn't seem
to have materialized just yet we also
know further forward and learning the
Disney Sony situation so if that's what
you were here for then yeah I'd really
don't know what to say let's just keep
praying we were supposed to be getting a
statement from Disney today on the
matter but as nothing's come forward I
guess we can at least assume that they
are in negotiations or close to
finalizing the deal and that's
everything from the panel overall I was
expecting slightly more news on the
films and I was also hoping that we will
get some confirmation of guardians of
the galaxy volume 3 but guests are still
ironing the kinks out on it I'm very
happy that Kit Harington is appearing in
the MCU and his casting whilst a little
left-field I'm sure will give him a lot
of room to grow he was initially rumored
to be playing Wolverine which is a bit
of a shame as I would have loved to have
seen him in that role but those are some
pretty big shoes to fill so maybe this
is a better choice for him overall as
you can take the character and really
make it his own Jemma Chan's casting is
pretty left-field too I'm guessing the
producers must see a lot on her for this
recast and it's nice that she's getting
a bigger fleshed out role as she's a
great actress and definitely deserves
some time in the spotlight I feel like
they could have given us more black
panther and Black Widow and of course
addressed the spider-man situation but
it's clear that they're keeping their
cards close to their chest especially
with a stock dip meaning that they
potentially don't want to lose anything
more before it's all set in stone
obviously I love to hear your thoughts
on the panel and if you're happy with
the announcements or not comment below
and let me know and if you want to see
my breakdown of the Disney Plus
streaming shows from this morning then
make sure you click the video at the end
it covers everything you need to know so
hopefully I'll see you over there after
this if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on twitter
at definition whitey it's the best way
to get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content also just wanna let you know
that we're giving away a free copy of
John wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have
to do to be in with
of winning is to LIKE this video and
leave you thoughts on the face wall
panel in the comment section below
the win will be chosen at random on
September the 10th in the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]